le tour de magie n'est pas contenue dans
les dix-huit minutes merci où l'ancien
donc on va faire un voyage
effectivement en colombie et pour
démarrer ce tedx j'avais envie de vous
faire prendre un peu de hauteur et
prendre un peu de perspectives alors la
perspective où va la prendre de la
manière suivante on va faire rapide il
ya à peu près on va dire quelques
milliers d'années pour faire court
même si ça revient à une époque proche
de nous aujourd'hui et bien nos ancêtres
nos arrière arrière arrière grands
parents je ne sais pas où ça s'arrête
vivaient quelque part sur la planète
avec la nature il est en harmonie en
relation et en lien avec la nature
c'était pas forcément un choix
ils n'étaient pas d'autres alternatives
mais là où il était sur la planète
il devait avoir des liens d'alliance
pour vivre chasse et s'habiller se
protéger ce joaillier on va appeler ce
temps là le premier monde
et puis est arrivé un deuxième monde le
nôtre celui dans lequel on est
maintenant qui se caractérise par quoi
il va et se caractérise par rupture des
relations avec le vivant puisque nous
sommes à 80 % en ville
en tout cas dans l'est dans les zones
urbaines il se caractérise par un
morcellement des savoirs il se
caractérise par une perte de sens soula
surtout la rupture avec le vivant génère
une multitude de déséquilibre
physiologique évidemment climatique la
com 21 nous le rappelle santé
agriculture fin bref cette coupure de ce
qui nous fait être des êtres vivants
multiplier déséquilibres alors il est
évident qu'on va pas revenir au premier
c'est clair il est aussi évident qu'on
peut pas rester en l'état
dans le second est la proposition c'est
bien sûr de se dire et si on prenait le
meilleur du premier et du deuxième pour
inventer le troisième monde alors par
nature je ne sais pas ce qui sera sa
troisième manche puisqu'il nous reste à
l'inventer on peut déjà se mettre
quelques petites bricoles je pense qu'il
ya quelque chose a interrogé sur le
rythme et sur le rapport au temps
le petit panneau lampe je pense qu'il ya
quelque chose de l'ordre avec les mains
de la coopération et de la solidarité a
retrouvé à redévelopper je pense qu'il
faudra un peu sortir du cadre peut
ouvrir nos imaginaires et arrêter de
reproduire des idées qui nous ont amenés
dans cette impasse donc sortons du cap
pour inventer autre chose et peut-être
aurons-nous l'audace de pousser la porte
de la vie et du vivant pour retrouver
une alliance donc je sais pas ce que ça
donnera mais je pense que c'est par là
qu'il faudra qu'on aille alors pour
nourrir un peu ce troisième monde je
travaille depuis 20 ans avec des
sociétés qu'on a appelée précolombiennes
archaïque sauvage primitive autochtones
des qualificatifs qui rend le dialogue
difficile quand on dit à l'autre bonjour
le primitif au taureau sauvage archaïque
si on se parle et ça démarre un peu mal
voilà c'est la société des indiens que
guy quatre mille ans d'histoire et la
dernière sociétés précolombiennes encore
en état de marche
c'est comme si on pouvait discuter avec
des mayas et toi tu vois le monde
comment et comment on pourrait se parler
pour inventer la suite de notre histoire
comment j'ai rencontré ces gens là quand
j'étais jeune et gentil est maigre
bon bref j'étais guide de montagne et on
m'a dit en colombie il ya la plus haute
montagne du monde en bordure de mer 6000
mètres d'altitude 38 km de la mer des
caraïbes qui devrait aller y faire un
tour
guide de montagne ça me passionnait j'ai
eu un oedème pulmonaire à 4000 mètres de
l'eau dans les poumons puis l'oxygène
dans le sang
donc il n'y a pas quelqu'un qui s'occupe
de vous êtes mort j'ai eu la chance que
ces sauvages archaïque primitif et la
gentillesse de ramasser de mettre sur
une bulle de me descendre d'altitude
elle me sauver la vie j'ai retrouvé
douze ans plus tard l'une des deux
personnes qui m'a sauvé la vie
un indien vieil indien et je vais
demander mais finalement pourquoi vous
avez fait un détour vous être préoccupé
de moi pour me ramasser c'était un peu
compliqué pour vous pour que vous avez
fait ça et m'a répondu très sérieux
parce qu'on voulait pas laisser de
poubelles dans nos montagnes
et là je me dis tiens ce sont donc des
gens qui ont l'humour enfin j'espère
peut-être par c'est à dire des bricoles
voilà pour ma rencontre avec cette
société lorsque je leur ai dit quand
même merci marc sauvé la vie qu'est-ce
que je peux faire pour vous remercier
ils m'ont dit aide nous à récupérer nos
terres ancestrales moi je n'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai dit pas de problème
j'ai pris mon agenda en afrique du sud
rendre les terres aux indiens je m'en
occupe c'est sympa je suis reparti en
france évidemment pas tenu mon
engagement m'a fallu dix ans pour me
dire
est il important de marché ces mots dans
la vie donc je suis retourné en colombie
aujourd'hui on a racheté deux mille
hectares de terres sur ces deux mille
hectares de terre il ya quatre-vingts
familles 350 personnes les cours d'eau
recouvrent les forêts repousser les
perroquets revol
j'ai rien d'autre à vous dire que ça
parce que quand ça fonctionne avec la
vie reviens moi ya pas beaucoup de chose
à en dire
voilà pour ma rencontre avec cette
communauté et quel est le chemin qui m'a
amené à faire connaissance avec eux
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça pour ce
dialogue vers ce troisième monde qu'est
ce qui nous différencie
et qu'est ce qui les différencie nous
deux et eux de nous la grande différence
l'un peut évoquer c'est que ville
toujours et ont toujours vécu en lien
avec la nature
c'est pas un paysage comme chez nous la
nature était réduite au rang de matière
premières ressources naturelles quelque
chose d'esthétique un terrain loisirs
mais plus du tout quelque chose avec
lequel nous devrions être en
interrelation donc celle où cette
paysage
j'ai eu c'est encore pays sage donc
quelque chose qui est enseignant quelque
chose avec lequel il faut avoir un lien
pour continuer à vivre un minima en
équilibre avec le territoire qui nous
accueillent sans lequel nous risquons
fort de disparaître
donc ça aurait fait référence évidemment
à léonard qui musèle va prendre tes
leçons dans la nature et bien ce
peuple-là se développe fonctionne en
s'inspirant complètement de ce qui fait
la vie et qui n'est pas notre cas
donc la grande différence c'est que chez
nous comment gère-t-on le collectif
comment gère-t-on le commun eh bien on
met des gens dans des chambres chambre
des députés sénateurs on leur dit pour
des lots des lois et nous allons donc
suivre les lois de la république
et si elle nous arrange pas aussi on
envie de les changer par pont d'autres
lois donc fait on a des lois comme ça
qui change au gré de nos humeurs et de
nos intérêts évidemment avec les lois de
la nature ça marche pas comme ça
arrêtez-vous de respirer pour voir enfin
pas trop longtemps c'est là la loi de
base
et dire l'inspirent l'expliqué s'il n'a
pas cette respiration ciapa le souverain
le premier souffre quand on est le
dernier souffre quand on sent là ya pas
de vie ne pas respecter les lois du
vivant pas pour s'enfermer pour les
transcender c'est risqué d'aller vers
une société mortifère et sclérosante
donc que fonctionne par l'observation et
la mise en pratique donc pour moi il
pourrait être de formidables traducteur
non pas pour redevenir que guy mais
qu'est ce que ça pourrait vouloir dire
de vivre avec le vivant puisque nous
sommes aussi vivent donc on va pas aller
vivre comme les coquilles à nous de
réinventer qu'est ce que ça veut dire
c'est une espèce de biomimétisme si le
mot vous parle global il s'intéresse à
la fois sur ce que le vivant est capable
de proposer mais aussi sur la manière
dont le vivant fonctionne alors quand on
a dit ça il ya deux chambres réflexion à
mon avis qu'on pourra ouvrir pour ce
troisième monde
le premier c'est le genre de la
connaissance finalement comment je sais
ce que je sais bon oui c'est sans doute
papa maman l'école mes expériences on a
tous des parcours singuliers
mais on n'a jamais pris le temps de se
demander si ce savoir n'était pas un
savoir subjective comme le vôtre comme
le vôtre comme tous les savoirs des gens
qui sont dans cette salle subjectif
singulier comment se sont ils
constituent la solution répond pas à
cette question on ne répond pas à quels
sont les lunettes que je porte sur le
nez qui me permettent de dire ça c'est
vrai ça c'est faux on n'en sait rien une
première question qu'on pourra
interroger sais que guy ces indiens
ont-ils un autre chemin d'accès au
savoir et lequel est la deuxième
question c'est comment faire société
questions d'actualité quand on regarde
la presse c'est pas encore gagné
il ya peut-être quelque chose aussi
apprendre sur le comment faire société
en harmonie avec le vivant et non par
l'opposition alors sur le comment je
sais ce que je sais je développe pas dû
beaucoup mais je prendrais juste un
petit exemple
deux de ces indiens que guidon vous avez
vu quelques images sont au laboratoire
d'astrophysique de londres avec deux
scientifiques dont professeur elie
stealth astronomes ils présentent au que
guy aux deux indiens présent des photos
de satellite hubble donc satellite en
limite l'atmosphère terrestre avec des
gros appareils photo qui prend des
photos sur les temps de pause de 13 14
15 heures pour aller capter ce qu'on
appelle des images parlent parce
qu'elles sont évidemment pas visible de
la terre et les indiens pointent leurs
doigts sur les
sur des taches blanches pardon en disant
ça c'est des étoiles et on les voit pas
de la terre et derrière il ya d'autres
étoiles
comment pouvait-il connaître l'existence
d'une étoile particulièrement pâle nous
avons découvert l'existence grâce à
cette image profonde de hubble space
telescope
je n'ai pas pu m'empêcher de me demander
de quels autres secrets surprenant où
les mêmes où étaient les détenteurs ça
révèle sans doute qu'il ya d'autres
manières d'accéder à la connaissance et
n'importe quelle démarche scientifique
consisterait à dire raconte explique
guitare valider ou invalider mais en
tout cas à s'engager pour les savoir de
quoi il s'agit
deuxième chose sur le vivre ensemble je
vous prendrai qu'un exemple la justice
par exemple dans nos sociétés quand
quelqu'un commet un acte délictueux on
va le juger on va le mettre en prison et
on va lui dire eh bien tu vas passer un
certain temps en prison pour régler la
dette qui paient la dette à la société
et quand tu auras payer sa dette
on verra comment tu reviens dans le
système ça va d'accord d'accord ou pas
jésus celle inverse si quelqu'un commet
un acte délictueux c'est qu'il est déjà
sorti du système puisqu'il ne
rrespectent plus les règles
donc le problème n'est pas de le faire
sortir encore plus le prêt mais de le
remettre dans le système
première chose deuxième chose il ya
jamais un monsieur ou une dame tout seul
qui commet un acte délictueux sortie de
son contexte
donc ils vont se poser la question quel
est le rôle des enseignants des parents
des amis des voisins qui n'ont pas fait
ce qu'il fallait faire pour que ce jeune
homme ou sept jeunes filles ou de
garçons peuvent sorte qu'ils le
respectent pas le système
donc c'est une responsabilité collective
et c'est pas le sortir plus mais le
faire rentrer oui c'est exactement l
inverse
parce qu'on est dans des logiques que
certains connaissent peut-être qu'on
appelle la systémie ya pas un coupable
qu'on met en prison et qu'on règle le
problème
voilà alors ses impacts évidemment la
santé vision holistique de la santé
c'est un impact à peu près tous les
domaines de connaissances qui sont les
nôtres
aurait-on aura-t-on la curiosité
l'audace intellectuelle dose et
l'exploration de ces savoirs non pas
pour dire ils ont faux ou exact juste
c'est de la violence
on va trouver sur des pistes pour ce
troisième monde
alors ça m'amène un peu sur le final
vous dire ceci il me semble qu'on est
dans un paradigme un système de
représentation des choses système de
représentation qui organise nos actions
bien évidemment qu'ils partiraient bas
de ce qui nous anime
ce sont des désir compulsif d'achat tout
ce que vous voulez de reproduction de
voilà on est dans cette espèce de désir
et la satisfaction du désir génère du
plaisir donc pourquoi se priver
compulsifs ou même un moment où on
s'arrête que les enfants s'ennuient faut
vite leur mettre un truc dans les mains
il ya des écrans de vidéos partout on
n'a aucun moment où les fruits peut se
poser pour réfléchir à autre chose
c'est cette espèce de désir compulsif
qui guident pour l'instant nos sociétés
les machines et les outils sont mis au
service de l'internet les premiers sites
de rencontres en ligne les signes porno
au programme le plus gros chiffre
d'affaires faut pas l'oublier
donc toutes les machines sont au service
de ce désir compulsif et complète de
gagner de l'argent évidemment derrière
vous avez la valeur de la compétition il
n'y a pas de place pour tout le monde
donc on voit bien les déséquilibres qui
s'instaure partout entre les plus riches
et les plus pauvres
ensuite on pense aux personnes alors là
j'étais avec un client à midi dans une
grosse boîte dont je tairai le nom
bah oui c'est le deuxième suicide parce
que c'est un phénomène en termes de
principes du vivant qu'on appelle
l'apoptose quand une cellule n'est plus
en lien avec le système avec lequel elle
a une relation normalement eh ben elle
meurt phénomène d'apoptose c'est lui qui
meurent dont quentin collaborateurs les
plus en lien
il avait été mis au placard avec le
système il s'est suicidé est un principe
de base
couper tous les liens sociaux pour m
peut-être la personne dehors alors
réactions dans cette boîte
ah bah vous avez entendu parler d'un
succès de récemment non on sait pas
comment comment réagir à ça donc valeur
de compétition par place pour tout le
monde les personnes il ya un petit
éclair rouge pas très confortable dans
la nature
c'est quoi ce truc je rappelle c'est ce
qui passe là-dedans
les mystères qui font que vous êtes là
en face de moi qu'on respire est qu'on
est vivant mais c'est tout en bas alors
je parle souvent de le concept du
sablier où elle commença sablier plus on
retourne on met un rôle vivant alors le
vivant au sens comment fonctionnent ces
fameux principe du vivant dans la
respiration il ya un principe de base
qui est le deux inspirations
l'expiration
je rappelle que jusqu'à présent pour
faire des bébés j'ai déjà fait des bébés
certains on nous l'a priori non et oui
il y en a qui savent pas trop ce qu'ils
ont fait mais bref il ya un homme et une
femme
ils font un câlin je rappelle que
normalement dans lequel un c'est un acte
d'amour
on n'est pas là en train de se dire bon
alors est-ce que j'ai bien mis les clefs
sur la simple tenue fin j'espère pour
vous n' ait quelque chose n'est quelque
chose un petit garçon et une petite
fille qui n'est ni la copie de la maman
ni la copie du pape a quitté un être à
part entière cirque de la rencontre de
deux énergies masculine et féminine est
quelque chose donc le principe du deux
est un principe de base
j'ai pas vous le détailler on le
retrouve partout normalement dans le
corps social plus ou moins utilisé voilà
pour partir du vivant bas les gens
travailler avec les gens le vivent
s'intéresse aux personnes continué en
disant plutôt des valeurs de coopération
parce que la nature porte des valeurs de
coopération contrairement à ce qu'on
pense plutôt que la compétition
évidemment garder les outils et les
machines au service est alors le
désirent ce serait dommage une vie sans
désir désir c'est un peu ce qui nous met
en mouvement mais j'ai pas certains
d'entre vous ont vu le film l'homme qui
chuchotait à l'oreille des chevaux qui
murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux
certains l'ont vu bon c'est l'histoire
d'un dresseur je mets des guillemets
parce qu'il est un peu particulier et
d'un cheval fin des chevaux est plutôt
que de dresser les chevaux en voulant
contenir son énergie ou en voulant
contenir l'énergie c'est le désir pardon
c'est comment je l'appris voise comment
nous rentrons dans une relation pour ce
désir existe mais ne me dépasse pas du
spinoza tout craché voilà donc ce serait
est-ce qu'on serait capable de repartir
du vivant pour garder qu'est ce que ça
voudrait dire dans nos sociétés modernes
en s'inspire
bien évidemment des copies comme
interprète et non pas comme modèle parce
qu'on va pas devenir tous indiens demain
à valenciennes c'est leur reste la
posture la posture du mutant qui
accepteraient ce renversement de
paradigme voilà un chaman qui a passé 18
ans dans le noir avant de faire son job
de chabannes et je voulais juste vous
dire une anectode sur lui et pour moi
est important un jour ils sont nés en
france
lui fait partie du voyage et nous avons
été reçus au quai d'orsay à paris le
quai d'orsay s'est la partie politique
où on reçoit à la france reçoit les
délégations donc nous avons été reçus
avec trois gars républicains à droite et
quatre à gauche
tac boum au forum ça le travail et pour
exposer la situation de ces indiens gens
ne reçoivent nous écouter nous répondait
bien il suffit de déposer un dossier au
bureau 627 b qui sera étudiée dans
quelques mois est concluante va
peut-être un peu d'argent alors qu'il
venait de dire avant que ces indiens
vivaient un génocide et que tout ça a
été filmé par une caméra c'était un peu
décalé la réponse administrative au
regard de nous sortons de la salle
nous nous retrouvons dans le hall
d'accueil du ministère karl a essayé
d'imaginer la scène les ors de la
république
j'étais en train de dire au revoir
madame merci au revoir monsieur le chef
de cabinet et là il ya un indien qui
sont réglés à temps
il voit un très beau quand même ça
canapé et sur le canapé il prend un peu
le ton avec des très beaux fils dorés il
le met sur son épaule et ils sont là
vers la sortie
oui l'air de rien alors je vois encore
la dame qui me disait en bois qui se fit
son polochon du regard le conte ils sont
avec le mobilier et le garde
républicaine qui suit le truc qu'il
devait pas voir sur ces consignes et
quand les gens s'en vont avec les
meubles qu'est ce qu'on fait pourquoi je
vous dis ça parce que on leur fait une
réponse absurde quelque part remplira
dossier alors et ils savent répondre par
une forme d'humour poétique et je pense
que la plus belle des énergies et la
plus belle des postures humaine qu'on
peut importer pour conduire cette
mutation qui nous attend et nous le
savons tous qu'elle soit vers le
troisième monde ouvert autre chose peu
importe
en outre l'humour et la poésie parce que
la poésie c'est la dernière chose la
racine du mot poésie s'est créé c'est la
création c'est à dire chose qui nous
relie au monde donc à la capacité de
créer c'est quand la raison d'or que la
création dont nous avons besoin peut
s'exprimer et que le poète doit venir au
rendez vous juste pour se terminer sur
ce monsieur est sûre leur posture il ya
quelque chose c'est très important chez
hausser le ton comment nourrir la
relation et le ton comment faire en
sorte que ce soit pas juste les
personnes mais ce qui se passe entre
elles qui m'importe
donc c'est des gens qui font passer
beaucoup de temps à faire des heures de
marche pour vous donner un fruit pour
venir vous aider dans un champ pour se
préoccuper de l'autre et un jour s'il ya
oui ce ton s'intéressant cette notion
donc je me suis je prends le tgv souvent
un matin 6 heures mais j'y tiens je vais
les prendre
j'étais assis vous êtes dans les plats
sur les 4 et 4 et 4 4 et 2 sont la
classe 8e valeo wagon-restaurant prend
deux trois quatre cafés et capté que je
reviens que mon plateau tgv le matin et
jeudi qui va à café la wii bien le film
il est malade il a mis la strychnine
c'est la caméra cachée qu'est-ce qui me
veut et c'est intéressant parce que le
don est un principe de base du vivant il
n'y a pas encore de compteurs sur le
soleil quand le matin au départ il ya du
soleil chouette
or le ton aujourd'hui est devenu anormal
puisque tenez ça cache quelque chose
donc c'est juste une petite illustration
humoristique vous dire comment on
pourrait réinvestir le lien qui réunit
les hommes
pour moi il faudrait de l'humour de
l'audace de la cohérence plus oser oser
demander osé parler aux aspects de
relations osé avoir une idée qui était
peut-être un peu incongru au départ
alors j'ai hésité pour la fin entre deux
citations du coup je envie d'hésiter ce
soir là donc j'ai mis les deux pour
conclure la première c'est une phrase
d'élisée reclus un géographe qui disait
l'homme c'est la nature prenant
conscience d'elle-même
il a dit ça au 19e siècle je mens c'est
notre défi non pas prendre conscience de
la nature les arbres les animaux c'est
pas ça dont je parle
prendre conscience de ce qui nous rend
vivant la systémie le 2 le don tout ce
que je vous ai un peu évoquée pour voir
comment ça peut reprendre sa place dans
nos sociétés urbaines et puis la
deuxième que je vous ai mis c'est celle
de saint-exupéry il faut avoir des rêves
assez grand pour éviter qu'ils le disent
est-ce pour s'engager vers ce troisième
monde on a intérêt à voir des sacrés
rêve sacrément grand sacrément joyeux
comme ça mon avion on arrivera à les
faire sortir ses rêves
voilà je suis à 00 00 18 minutes c'est
tac tac au tac x merci de m'avoir permis
d'inaugurer cette soirée